your doctor may recommend laparoscopic
surgery to repair a ventral incisional
hernia a ventral hernia can be seen as
an abnormal bulge beneath the skin of
your abdomen the Bulge may be your
intestines which are located inside your
abdomen
a thin membrane called the peritoneum
covers most of your abdominal organs
including your intestines your abdominal
muscles surround the peritoneum and your
skin covers the abdominal wall these
three layers cushion and protect your
internal organs
if you have had abdominal surgery in the
past a ventral incisional hernia may
appear at the site of your surgical scar
here your intestine pushes through a
weakened spot in the tissue between your
abdominal muscles creating a bulge
beneath your skin the peritoneal tissue
surrounding the herniated intestine is
called the hernia sac if your hernia is
not repaired complications may occur for
example the hernia opening may trap a
loop of your intestine which can
partially or completely block passage of
its contents resulting in a condition
called intestinal obstruction symptoms
such as pain vomiting and constipation
may occur intestinal obstruction may
cause strangulation a condition in which
blood flow is cut off to your intestine
as a result a segment of your intestine
may die
before your procedure an intravenous
line will be started and you may be
given a sedative to help you relax you
will be given general anesthesia which
will put you to sleep for the duration
of the operation a breathing tube will
be temporarily inserted through your
mouth and into your throat to help you
breathe
during the operation a catheter may also
be placed in your bladder to drain your
urine
to begin the procedure your surgeon will
make a small incision in your abdomen
then place a small tube called a port
into the incision then your surgeon will
pump carbon dioxide gas through the port
into your abdomen expanding it to allow
him or her to see your abdominal organs
more easily next your surgeon will make
another incision near your umbilicus or
bellybutton and insert another small
port
through this port your surgeon will
insert a laparoscope which is a tiny
camera that projects images onto a TV
monitor to guide your surgeons work
while viewing the inner surface of your
abdomen your surgeon will make two more
incisions and insert two more ports next
your surgeon will insert narrow surgical
instruments through these ports to begin
the repair scar tissue from previous
operations will be removed if necessary
then your surgeon will cut away the
hernia sack allowing your intestine to
return to its proper location in your
abdomen next your surgeon will suture a
piece of mesh over the weak spot in the
abdominal wall to prevent your intestine
from slipping back through the opening
your surgeon will examine the area for
bleeding or other damage and repair as
necessary a port valve will be left in
place briefly to allow all the carbon
dioxide to escape from the abdomen
finally your surgeon will remove the
instruments and close the incisions with
sutures or staples
after your procedure the breathing tube
and catheter will be removed and you'll
be taken to the recovery area for
monitoring you will be given pain
medication as needed when you are able
to drink liquids your intravenous line
will be removed you may go home the same
day or stay overnight in the hospital to
aid the healing of your hernia avoid
heavy lifting bending and twisting for
several weeks after your procedure